one more clip I want to look at with you
today
without making fun of anyone
one of the things we've been talking
about this week and last in the context
of the midterm elections
when doing interviews like our
correspondent Luke Beasley did at a
trump rally over the weekend we have
talked about we're not joking here this
is serious we've talked about how
difficult it can be to distinguish what
is a cult member who has been
brainwashed what is an ignorant person
and what is a mentally ill person when
someone says I think JFK Jr is alive and
is the president right now
is that something that you believe
because you're part of a cult
is that something you believe because
you just don't realize the truth about
JFK Jr and when he was killed and how or
is that something you say because you're
mentally ill or is it all three in some
combination the
epitome of this Venn diagram
is a tour called reawaken America
Eric Trump one of Donald Trump's
children has been a regular attendee at
these events this is a little clip from
right before Tuesday's election where
they are
striking the ground with imaginary
arrows to call upon God to win the
midterm elections for them
[Music]
Victory shoutlets strike the ground and
let's give a victory Shout
on the count of three are you ready yeah
so here we go get your arrows out just
go strike
and strike and strike strike
come on keep going strike come on strike
come on strike the ground
they've got the band and everything huh
that's right come on come on
this is this is I'm cringing I'm really
cringing come on
[Music]
come on victory victory victory victory
victory
okay
where is this on our Venn diagram where
is this on the Venn diagram of cult
brainwashing simple ignorance and mental
illness I think it's a very difficult
question and I think it's an interesting
question it's not about making fun of
these people now you know why it didn't
work right you know why Oz lost and
fetterman won I was striking with
imaginary arrows against us and it just
canceled it out I did it so correctly
and accurately I'm kidding but that's
why this is all so insane I don't know
the answer
I genuinely don't know the answer I
don't know whether we say this is a form
of mental illness and delusion
whether these are just folks who have
been brainwashed or whether they
ignorantly believe that striking the
ground with fake arrows affects election
results I do not know but Michael Flynn
and Eric Trump regularly participate in
these events and the interplay the
blending between
sort of elected officials although Eric
Trump isn't an elected official but
political individuals and these types of
extreme religious events there is no
fine line between them anymore they are
together the American right-wing
political establishment and the extreme
I think these are Evangelical folks
Evangelical right-wing establishment
have blended into one and that's where
we are it's really scary stuff let me
know what you make of it I used to say
find me on Twitter Twitter is
increasingly unusable because of what's
going on so make sure you're subscribed
on YouTube make sure you're following on
Twitch make sure you've liked us on
Facebook I want to hear from you where
is this on that
Spectrum or or Circle or triangle of
ignorance cult brainwashing and mental
illness let me know what you think
you've heard me talk about the accounts
we've had hacked it's a horrible
experience it can happen to anyone look
up the stats if it hasn't happened to
you yet it may at some point protecting
yourself against scammers online can get
complicated our sponsor Aura is the
all-in-one solution that I now use to
keep accounts safe Aura scans the dark
web for your personal info emails
passwords Social Security numbers
immediately alerts you if anything is
found helps you fix the problem you also
get alerts about suspicious credit
inquiries Aura automatically requests
the removal of your information from
search engines and data broker sites and
Aura protects all of your devices from
malware with its state-of-the-art
antivirus and Aura also helps you manage
what your kids can do on their devices
with very simple easy to use parental
device controls you can try or a free
for two weeks at aura.com Pacman your
login credentials might already be
floating around round it takes only a
few seconds on Aura to figure that out
and think of all of the other useful
things you'll discover during the
two-week trial the link is down below